so there's two groups of people when it
comes out to subject to multitasking and
you'll know which one you are there's a
part that says I'm a great multitasker
you ever heard people say I am very good
at multitasking I can do a lot of
different things at the same time and
I'm effective and then there's another
side that says there's no way in the
world you can multitask I do one thing
but I do one thing very very good don't
multitask and this is a great question
to be asking yourself but to me what I
like to do with a subject like this is
to try to get as much clarity as
possible so today's goal is to help get
clear about the subject of multitasking
or doing one thing at a time
so prior to getting into that the first
thing we ought to ask ourself is so in
order to do multitasking that means we
are doing multiple different things at
the same time so that means there are
habits that are being formed to do
multitasking right you need habits to be
formed and one of the best things I read
about in this book called the power of
habit is scientists have done studies to
find out why the brain likes to create
habits and the answer to me was
unbelievable I showed on a conference
call this morning it totally made me
look at a habit in a complete different
way the reason why your brain creates
new habits is because the brain likes to
be lazy and take a break to do the
things that really matter the most so
the brain creates new habits to become
automatic so it doesn't think about it
anymore it does it automatically
without having to use up any energy for
small tasks so what does it mean to you
and I right what does it mean to you and
I okay walking you and you walk you
don't think about walking it's a habit
that was formed breathing it's an
automatic your brain doesn't think about
breathing anymore right if you think
about brushing your teeth nobody needs
to tell you about brushing your teeth
anymore but
it was a formula on why you and I brush
our teeth today exercising if you have
that habit there was a way that it
created that habit of you and I exes
there's a Formula Ford right
good or bad habits there's a formula on
how you and I picked up the good end of
bad habit and so if you can figure out
as an entrepreneur one that one of the
things about an entrepreneur running an
organization it is very very important
to identify what those good and the bad
habits are what new good habits you want
to create to make the brain become
automatic and prior to me getting into
the message I'm I talked about how to
create new habits I'm going to talk
about how to create new habits in your
entire organization how to drop bad
habits as well as the willpower to
create new habits I want to give you an
example about multitasking and doing one
thing at a time so Mario why don't you
come on up here let me show everybody
here on what we're doing here I'm going
to explain multitasking and doing one
task at a time with the analogy of
basketball and say I'm the point guard
and I have the ball and Mario is a
defender and I'm playing a full-court
game with five other team before other
teammates and how many different
activities I have to be thinking about
so watch this I have the ball more use
the defender look at the Activity one I
have to bring the ball back to I step
forward here three you have to look at
its foot to see if I go left four I have
to watch out for the push-off Heastie is
putting me here right five I have to
look for my player that's coming for a
screen and if I go left he's gonna come
defending he's gonna leave right yeah I
have to look at my coach that signaling
me telling me what play to run the fan
that's saying bad things to me and
cursing me out my shooter over there
that's open the guy that's cut you know
I have to pay attention to so many
different things as a point guard I'm
multitasking so I come here more you
could go for my knees he could do a
Dellavedova if you know what I'm talking
about then then I go for the shot when I
go for the shot I can shoot the shot but
he's still going to try to block it
right so this is an example of playing
the game and happened to multitask in
order to compete at this level if I
don't know how to multitask you know I
am NOT ever going to be in the NBA
because I need to learn how to multitask
now watch the difference this is an
individual task so if I shoot
field-goal the chances of me making it
is relatively 45 to 50 percent okay 40
to 50 percent depending on my skill
level but free-throw shooter I'm only
doing one task at a time watch when I
say one task I dribble the ball maybe
that's one activity then my knees bring
my hands up elbow aims wrists look at
the back of the rim ball goes in 80%
chance free throw 45% field goal so the
efficiency on free throw will always be
higher than a multitasker shooting but
to make it at the highest levels and
compete at the highest level you got to
learn how to multitask where the
footwork the screen the eyes everything
becomes automatic as your brains no
longer thinking about it because you've
already created that habit and you need
to work to be efficient with that one
task in hand because if you want to make
it at a highest level as an entrepreneur
you got to be built with both good at
multitasking and being efficient at one
effective activity so now the question
becomes how do I create a new habit
we're going to talk about that next so
if that's the example of you know
multitasking and doing one task at a
time the player versus the free-throw
shooter you've got to know that when
you're running a business and you're
having a complaint and you have somebody
that's doing this and somebody that's
doing that and you have your family
calling you you know kids are this you
got to drop this person off you got to
have commitment in your payment car
payment and sure we are doing so many
different tasks that's the extreme and
how do you manage being that so you
don't have an explosion taking place and
on the other side you also need to be
extremely quiet at times and get away
and turn off the music turn off the
phones and be silent and ask the
question when there's no movement
nothing else to worry about no phones no
music no nothing there's nothing else
going on we think better right we think
better but if you only try to create
this as a lifestyle and only keeping
everything quiet the real world of
running an entrepreneur and running a
business and all the millions of things
that could take place you're going to be
overwhelmed here you got to learn how to
react to you this is my players mentally
and emotionally you got to be prepared
when they played in the
big leagues and everybody's watching us
a lot more movement you gotta know how
to handle that and it always goes back
to being mentally emotionally strong
when those moments come and it typically
goes back to the habits that you put
into your mind that's become automatic
so now the question becomes okay so how
do we create new habits the formula is
actually very simple on how to create
new habits for for your business or life
or whatever maybe we're right now for
the example we're using is is say
business so go back to when we were kids
so think about it some things that you
do on a daily basis that we don't think
about anymore when you brush your teeth
is there somebody that tells you to
brush your teeth and if you brush your
teeth you're going to be given a gift or
anything like that not at all but
there's a formula that our parents used
on us to brush our teeth that we've been
using for 20 30 40 50 60 years and we
don't even know about it right we have
all these great habits that we have in
our lives that was taught many years ago
good and bad sometimes and we don't even
know about it but it was programming
many many years ago give you an example
so let's use brushing your teeth as an
example what is the formula to create a
new habit first is the cue you got have
a cue for your new habit step number two
is the actual habit the routine and step
number three is the reward so cue habit
reward I want my son my 80 month old son
to learn how to brush his teeth okay cue
when we go take a bath together son he
knows the next step is brushing your
teeth the routine cue is taking a bath
cue could be were going upstairs cue
could be it's time to go take a bath get
us the cue routine we brush his teeth
the reward he gets to watch one episode
of Thomas and Friends hypothetically he
gets to play with his toys
hypothetically that's the reward
exercise cue routine reward cue alarm
goes up cue a motivational recording is
set to go off at five o'clock in the
morning
whatever recording you listen to Tony
Robbins a motivational video on YouTube
it just gets you fired up your
affirmations that's your cue the routine
getup splash cold water go to the gym do
the routine it's your exercise the
reward I come home I watch an episode of
whatever you know you want to watch an
episode of a show you follow or
madmen or house of cards or whatever it
is at 6:30 in the morning
or you're going to make yourself a
blueberry yogurt whatever you make you
know you're going to have Nutella I
don't know for your cheat in the morning
to have your carbs and then that's your
cue your actual routine and your reward
that's the programming on how to create
habits this works in for you to create
new habits for yourself for your staff
or your agents for your employees for
your kids for your family it's the
formula that works effectively on how to
create new habits now with that being
said let's talk about bad habit so
what's the good news and the bad news
about bad habits so a lot of times we
think a bad habit can be dropped
permanently it's always going to be good
right okay hey honey we're going to get
married and none of my bad habits are
ever going to show up great that sounds
very very good in a perfect world
unfortunately we're not living in a
perfect world and so bad habits are
almost like a bankruptcy you had nine
and a half years ago it's going to show
up when you apply for an executive job
right you've been good for nine and a
half years but it's still going to show
up a bad habit is like a you know three
late fees you had on a car payment six
years ago that you've been good for six
years but it's looking at show up on
your credit score a bad habit could be
you know a bad habit could be something
you did many many years ago that is
still in the back of your mind
and you have to fight it off right so
bad habits are never destroyed bad
habits
- to be able to fight it off it just
gets easier and easier and easier if
you've created new habits to replace bad
habits but a bad habit is not like
control-alt-delete boom I'm going to put
it in the trash it's gone it's never I
don't even know about it it's gone no we
don't have those what is that movie with
Tommy Lee Jones and Will Smith they were
it was it anything that they put in your
face and you forget about what happened
what was that machine that they were
using you know what I'm talking about
though right so they would do that a
boob it's gone that doesn't exist bad
habit stays right you can't get rid of
it so you can't get rid of it from your
mind but you can replace it and
reprogram it with new habits so this
exercise helps with replacing that new
habit in your mind that we just talked
about right now now let's talk about
organized
because a lot of times if you look at
the organization okay when when somebody
asks and says hey come and look at my
office and see how I'm doing or come
look at my business and assess my
business and see how I'm doing in and
and find out what we're doing over here
in our organization in our office
whatever though the best way I like to
do it is I don't want to talk to them
because we all know how to give the
right answers right you're going to talk
to somebody and they give you the right
answers and they say hypothetically that
the Yahoo yeah we're supposed to do this
and we work this and we do this and we
do that sounds great because we know the
right answers the right answers is what
how many times do you exit I try to
exercise five days a week what's your
diet like I try to stay away from sugars
I try to stay away from fat I try we
know all the right answers now what we
know and answer and what we do are
completely different so the best way to
to gauge an organization is to talk to
the people in that organization so when
I go and talk to a group and I see the
bad habits that the group has if it's 10
15 20 people that have that bad habit it
comes from the top okay so if the bad
habit is then none of them like to go
out there and sell and get on the phones
well that fear from the phones comes
from the top if I if I if I assess an
organization and not unlike to go out
there and sell on the field that comes
from the top right if you look at the
organization and you know none of them
work that hard it comes from the top if
they're very effective it comes from the
top if they're very respectful it comes
from the top if they're sloppy it comes
from the top no matter what it is
generally the good and the bad habits
are coming from the top down so when a
leader at the top decides to create new
habits in an organization to tell you
the results of that are positively
compounding ly incredible I can't even
describe it to you you know we we are in
our organization we we decided to make
of reading books and absolute obsession
to make that a habit and to tell you the
consequences that's brought to our
organization I can't even put a word to
it I can't put a number to it it's it's
infinitely grown with the level of
thinking because it's a new
there's many new habits that we
constantly work on adding to the
organization so how do you create new
habits in your organization well first
you've got to make a list and this is
not a perfect exercise this is a real
honest exercise what are the good habits
of your office your business your
organization what are the bad habits and
where do they learn about habits from ok
and what did I learn the good habits
from that's a good exercise because you
realize many the good habits will come
to you and then some of the good habits
are leaders on your organization your
company that have their own identities
because they're better than you in that
area it's good because that's a good
habit that can rub up on other people
and learn if you can allow that person
to share those good habits with
everybody else but the bad habits are
areas that you'll see a lot of it will
come to you and you got to be able to
identify this so good habits bad habits
all right
then you write down what new habits I
want to instill in my organization what
are some new habits I want to fill my
organization I want to instill reading
books great I want to instill hard work
great I want to stop people staying late
without even being asked to do because
they want to do because they're in love
with the company and they're in love
with the cause great I want to I want to
have their team work in my environment
great I want people to be thinking
bigger I want to create a habit of you
know competing I want to create a habit
of you know going out there listening to
CDs I want to create a habit of people
no longer listen to the radio in the car
I'm going to create a habit of not
drinking coffee or drinking coffee
whatever it may be the habit you want to
create I want to create the habit of our
leaders exercise on a lot more because
if they exercise their sharp if they're
sharper
they feel better about themselves they
do better business what can I do to get
that habit of exercising in that
organization that comes from you ok
formula let's go to it 1 how do you
create good new habits in your
organization 1 figure out which small
habits which habits lead to small wins
ok so what happened can I instill that
leads to a small win a small victory for
that individual so it's not putting
something very big together it's putting
something very small together here's the
victory for you if you can do this you
have this victory ok so once you link a
habit to a small victory it's not a very
difficult task to do that everybody can
slowly but surely doing next thing you
know you're seeing growth and a new
clear
I've been being instill for that month
at you got to stay on it because if you
don't stay on it nothing happens so step
number two is you actually staying on it
now doing it one time and you think it's
going to change everything no if you do
it one time it's not real people think
you just got excited about something you
try something new and you got off of it
it's continuously staying on that
message one month two months three
months I always say takes 90 to 180 days
to create a new culture or new habit in
an organization it doesn't happen
overnight okay then those small wins
that they have themselves create a
relatively minimal award but lead to a
chain reaction of much larger rewards so
I have a small victory I start thinking
I can have a bigger victory now I'm
stretching myself for something else now
organization sees most of the people by
the way come out with a new initiative
for your organization know this eighty
percent are not going to do it because
they don't take you seriously but the 20
percent that doing they know it is to 20
percent getting results
remember not everybody's a leader most
people follow and they wait for somebody
else doing it until they say I'm going
to try it again I'm gonna try mines for
myself as well because it's working so
good for Bobby Bobby that's so good and
Bobby you know has grown his business
last month he made fifty eight thousand
dollars great you know he's grown his
office so while he's doing so great with
his business he's doing so I'm going to
take up that new habit is when I'll try
but don't expect everybody to do right
off the bat generally a new habit being
instill this is what it looks like goes
like this and it goes like this
everybody's excited efforts to trying it
out then they notice there is no instant
results within two weeks four weeks six
weeks so they drop doing it because they
don't believe it works but enough people
will stick with it so those people that
drop out these guys have a lead on them
in a major way then when they notice
that they're separating they don't like
that so they not have to catch up and
some of these guys will make this a
permanent tablet that they will not even
stop doing it so then you have a
separation because this guy took it
seriously and this guy didn't right this
happens in every organization now if the
guy at the top that took a new habit he
falls off they have the drops discussed
as a mob the challenge is to create a
new habit and stay on that habit for as
long as possible that becomes automatic
you're no longer thinking about doing it
reading a book is a prompt Oh music
morning ten minutes boom I'm going to
the gym Q routine reward Q routine
reward and it's automatic soda make like
the basketball player automatic defense
shot clock scream shooter elbow block
you know foul all that stuff is going
automatic automatic you're not thinking
about it no more in that moment you know
how to multitask and a last but not
least cultivating positive habits can
completely transform an organization if
you do it and if you stay on it that can
completely change an entire organization
in order to do that in order to stay on
a habit there is one last thing in order
to stay on a habit the one last thing to
stay on a habit is you know we hear it
all the time we hear in sports all the
time you know he he he willed them into
victory the last one to create a new
habit is willpower and willpower is
something that it comes from you the
leader it comes from the individual that
wants to create a new habit it comes
from you the entrepreneur that wants to
create a new habit a new culture in your
organization takes discipline and the
great thing about willpower again
scientists have done a study a lot of
time people used to say what power is a
you know characteristic and it's part of
a human being in the way they are
actually it's not willpower I was a very
very lazy kid when I was younger I was a
was not the hardest-working kid when I
was 14 years old I had a lot of bad
habits you couldn't say two had
willpower you couldn't get me to do
homework you can't get me to finish a
chapter of a book let alone read an
entire book so nobody would have said I
had strong willpower no as I joined the
army and I got and became an
entrepreneur I wanted to win big as an
entrepreneur that willpower was a muscle
that I developed you know just like
bodybuilding I was 6 1 135 at 14 years
old I had to develop muscles willpower
is also a muscle to develop that you as
a leader can develop and then from there
you start developing within your
teammates but this is a challenge with
willpower so makes me something about
willpower you ever catch yourself doing
a lot of things throughout the day and
it's nonsense things that you're doing
let me clean out my desk great let me
you know check my facebook let me check
the email here let me send this thing
over here oh let me send that
over there all the tedious things that
you're doing guess what all of that
takes away from your willpower because
every day we have a dosage of willpower
and if you allow nonsense activity to
use up your willpower then you barely
have any willpower to use when you need
it for bigger things that make sense so
it's very very important to look at your
willpower as a gas tank every day you
have a certain amount of willpower in
your mind if you waste it on tedious
activities the big activities when it
requires a big willpower to push it
through you're too tired you're mentally
exhausted because you've wasted your
willpower in all smaller than habits
that are irrelevant instead of the
habits that create you money so you've
got to also be very very uh pay very
close attention to where you're using
your willpower to to waste this stuff
instead of the bigger items that you
want to do and eventually you know great
thing about a willpower you more and
more you do the more repeated you're
doing it eventually becomes automated
and no longer needs you to think about
what you need to be doing you know I'm
going to have a salad 30 days and
automatically every time you go your
waiter already knows I'm having the same
barbeque chicken salad double chicken
you know lunch portion bring it over
here I'll have an iced tea or I'll have
a water
iced lemon on the side and this this
this and and you're used to ordering the
you know da Vinci pasta or the chicken
piccata with the extra sauce on the side
and sounds good when you hear it right
at the Cheesecake Factory or you're
going to go and go get that garlic
chicken noodles with shrimp and the
sauce on the side well when you go to
the salad once twice three times for 15
20 30 days 40 days your willpower can
handle it smells everything else it's
over it and you stay on it it becomes a
discipline now it's automatic you don't
even think about anymore then I'll send
you a month later two months later three
months later you start touching your abs
you start feeling your shoulders your
legs American and shape men are more
efficient at work I feel good to my
family I have a lot more energy awake I
love reading books not like I can do so
much more I feel like I'm that athlete
that point god I'm getting better I'm
multitasking because your energy also
helps you have stronger willpower to get
new habits and stay consistent on your
habits as long as you're constantly
rewarding yourself many
times people want to create new habits
but they don't want to reward themselves
your brains got to know that I get
something good by doing something I'm
willing to do something as long as you
give me a reward at the end when I was
24 25 I don't know how wouldn't why
don't we get a hardy mori 24 25
something like that I told myself if I
have a certain amount of savings at that
time was a quarter million dollars I'm
gonna buy myself a heart it was a night
rod special kid had just come out it was
the anniversary one and I went out there
I had never written a Hardy before I
don't even know how to ride a Harley
I've never in my life ridden a
motorcycle before and I had a friend of
mine Jim God bless his soul he passed
away couple months ago he went with me
to the Artie Davidson we picked up the
Harley we brought it down to the office
and that night is when I learned how to
ride a motorcycle but it was my brain
knowing that if you create new habits
and new routines and this constant cue
there is a reward at the end so if you
don't have the reward it actually
backfires on you because your brain gets
annoyed with you that you're making it
doing things without the reward at the
end I know we covered a lot today
there's a lot of things we covered so I
know in your mind you're thinking what
do i do how do i what do i attack first
to work on but I want to tell you this
you know it's so many people want to
build a big business and so many people
want to be successful so many people
want to build a big empire that they're
proud of and there are so many articles
that we try to see maybe honey to do
this not need to do that no I need to do
this here's what I need to do generally
those who build a big Empire they become
very good at the fundamentals a good
basketball player has fundamental
footwork fundamental defense fundamental
screens fundamental passing John Wooden
won more than anybody else sticking to
the fundamentals this is a message of
fundamentals today and if you can learn
how to improve your own fundamentals and
become a better teacher fundamentals
going to help you out tremendously in
your business out so here's a few things
I want to encourage you to do one watch
the video one more time I know I covered
a lot watch the video one more time to
take up take out a paper and pen and
actually take notes on areas that we
covered posit write it down pause it
write it down and prepare not only for
yourself but also teaching it to your
team your organization that
teammates that you work with to make a
list of the new habits that you want to
actually instill and start creating the
way that I'm talking about the queue the
routine and the reward and those habits
throwing out a lot of them because if
you create too many of them at a time
you get over one don't get more than new
habits you want to add I suggest three
is the maximum number and then your
company the less habits you want to
instill the better it is three is the
magical number one is always good but
three is the max I don't suggest five I
suggest three there's a sweet spot right
in the middle if you think you can do
five that's fine can stretch up a threes
the number put the formula together for
that share this video with your
teammates and and and and and have them
see it as well so there's going to be a
lot of buying from them if you're
watching this and your executive
somebody share this with you you know
actually be the student and learn this
because this can do a lot for you once
you learn how to develop new habits for
your so because it can help you become
very very competitive it only benefits
you if you do this and then last but not
least become a master of teaching people
how to develop new habits if you become
a master of teaching people how to
develop new habits night and day what
happens with your business so the book I
recommend is the power of habits by a
author called Charles Duhigg power of
habit go by the book the link is in the
description as well so phenomenal book
there's a lot of good books to read on
this subject this is by far the best
book I've read on habits and I know a
lot of people ask what other books would
you recommend first read this book then
I'll recommend some other ones once you
finish it and then feel free to comment
on the bottom if you have any other
questions about the subject and if you
have any other comments you can post it
on the bottom as well and if you
actually go out and create these new
habits I want to hear about how it
worked out for you so we'd love to hear
your commentary on the results you've
gotten ever since instilling new habits
into yourself and your organization so
with that being said be sure to
subscribe to this channel and thanks for
watching
you